le système total anatomie d'une
multinationale de l'énergie documentaire
en quête réalisée par Jean-Robert
Viallet et coécrit avec Catherine Le
Gall comme l'image est trompeuse
l'entreprise totale énergie consacre
donc l'essentiel de sa communication aux
énergies vertes pourtant ces dernières
ne représentent qu'une très infime
partie de sa production de quoi
s'interroger plus au-delà sur les faux
semblants du greenwashing pratiqué entre
autres par ces mastodontes de
l'industrie pétrogaziaire c'est ce que
nous allons faire maintenant avec nos
invités présents aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau de débat doc avec vous pour
commencer barbara Pompili bienvenue vous
êtes ancienne ministre de la transition
écologique c'était entre juillet 2020 et
mais 2022 et aujourd'hui député de la
Somme apparentée au groupe Renaissance
vous avez entre autres porté le projet
de loi dit climat et résilience était en
2021 issus des travaux de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat dont l'un des
objectifs était bel et de renforcer la
lutte contre le blanchiment écologique
on y reviendra bien sûr avec vous dans
cette émission François Jemane est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
enseignants vous enseignez les
politiques du climat et des migrations
dans différentes universités notamment à
Sciences Po Paris et à l'Université
Libre de Bruxelles vous êtes également
chercheur au sein de l'Université de
Liège cette fois où vous dirigez
l'Observatoire Hugo et votre dernier
ouvrage s'intitule l'écologie n'est pas
un consensus dépassé l'indignation c'est
un ouvrage publié chez Faya qui enfin
avec nous Lucie pinson bienvenue à vous
vous êtes une militante pour la
transition écologique et ce d'assez
longue date maintenant vous êtes
fondatrice et directrice de l'ONG
réclame finance dont il a été question
dans ce documentaire on y reviendra
votre ONG Requiem finance promeut le
désinvestissement des énergies fossiles
on va en reparler avec vous bien entendu
également dans cette émission
greenwashing on va en donner une
définition une définition qui nous est
donnée par le Larousse parce que c'est
un anglicisme qui a fait son apparition
dans le Larousse c'est une technique
frauduleuse employée dans le domaine du
marketing et de la communication il
s'agit de promouvoir une image de marque
plus responsable éthique et écologique
qu'elle ne l'est en réalité ce
documentaire sur total énergie que nous
venons de voir est-ce que c'est un
parfait exemple de ce que peut-être le
greenwashing aujourd'hui oui on peut
dire que c'est un parfait exemple dans
la mesure où nous avons une entreprise
qui fait une offensive une offensive de
communication pour expliquer à quel
point ils vont se préoccuper de l'avenir
se préoccuper du climat se préoccuper
des personnes qui subissent le
réchauffement climatique avec
l'emblème qui est le changement non
c'est à dire que nous sommes nous étions
un pétrolier maintenant nous sommes les
fers de lance des énergies et donc
notamment
à Total énergie au pluriel au pluriel
donc c'est très on a au même envie de
les suivre on se dit finalement on est
dans un monde qui est très dépendant des
fossiles les premiers concernés qui sont
les producteurs d'énergie fossile
prennent le virage tant mieux
encourageant et on se rend compte assez
vite et moi j'en ai été témoin assez
fréquemment que ce virage ils le
prennent peut-être mais de manière très
très lente et que l'essentiel de leur de
leurs investissements de leur production
ça reste encore du fossile avec une
forme de cynisme qu'on voit d'ailleurs
dans ce dans ce documentaire
qui pourrait revenir dans les esprits
après avoir eu ce film il y a un chiffre
qui est cité au même titre que votre ONG
finance selon vous la part de la
production de Total énergie aujourd'hui
représenterait
0,38% des énergies produites par Total
énergie 0,38% ce chiffre vous le tirez
d'où exactement alors quand on regarde
les communications de l'entreprise et
notamment les dernières communications
donc à la fois le rapport énergie
Outlook publiée en septembre dernier ou
encore les communications en direction
des investisseurs de l'entreprise encore
il y a peu en vue de l'assemblée
générale qui se tient la semaine
prochaine et bien on voit que le total
en tout cas continue d'investir la
majeure partie de ces investissements
dans les énergies fossiles qui captent
plus des deux tiers des dépenses des
dépenses d'investissement avec un flou
qui est maintenu par Total dans une
qu'il appelle la catégorie bas carbone
dans laquelle on va trouver les énergies
renouvelables mais on va pas trouver que
les énergies renouvelables on va aussi
trouver la probabilité de production
d'électricité à partir de gaz qui reste
donc bien entendu une l'énergie fossiles
et lorsqu'on prend ces derniers chiffres
là on voit que la catégorie dite back
carbone capte donc moins d'un tiers des
dépenses d'investissement de Total et
que cette catégorie représentera moins
de 14% du mix à l'horizon 2030 il est
intéressant de ramener le les chiffres à
l'horizon 2030 et non à l'horizon 2050
puisque c'est bien maintenant que ça se
ça se joue
à l'horizon 2030 total on le sait d'ores
et déjà ça a été annoncé va consacrer
70% de ses investissements au gaz et au
pétrole tout à fait alors à la fois à la
production
de pétrole et de gaz donc c'est ce qui
se situe au niveau de l'extraction donc
des champs d'hydrocarbures et puis en
effet on voit que Total s'ils
l'entreprise se diversifie au delà du
secteur extractif et bien il demeure
orienter majoritairement ouvert les
énergies fossiles puisque sa
diversification repose sur la
pétrochimie le plastique sur le
naturelle liquéfiées puisque total
énergie est pas seulement la septième
entreprise à développer le plus de
nouveaux champs d'hydrocarbures c'est
aussi la douzième à développer le plus
ces terminaux de gaz naturel liquéfié
qui vont nous verrouiller dans un avenir
extrêmement carboné et puis c'est aussi
une entreprise qui développe au niveau
de la production d'électricité des
énergies qui sont pas du tout
soutenables vous qui observez ce qui se
passe sur l'entente
du marché
pétrolier et gazier on ferait le même
constat concernant toutes les majors de
ce secteur aujourd'hui je vais en citer
quelques-unes à un BP shell Texon etc
globalement oui on va avoir des
stratégies d'investissement qui reste
majoritairement orientés vers les
énergies fossiles avec une part à louer
aux énergies renouvelables qui demeurent
donc qui demeure donc très faible et
donc il faut bien rappeler le problème
avec cette stratégie d'expansion des
énergies fossiles pourquoi c'est un
problème c'est un problème tout
simplement parce que quand bien même
personne nous dit qu'il faut sortir du
pétrole et du gaz du jour au lendemain
ça c'est très clair ça va se maintenir
encore pendant plusieurs années en
revanche tout nouveau projet d'énergie
fossile qu'aujourd'hui développe va à
l'encontre de nos objectifs en matière
climatiques et ça c'est reconnu par les
scientifiques du GIEC c'est également
projeté dans les scénarios
1,5 degrés de l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie qui n'est pas du tout une
agence de conservation et de protection
de l'environnement et c'est bien entendu
aligné avec toutes les alertes et appel
à l'action lancer par Antonio guterese
qu'on a entendu encore une fois dans ce
dans ce documentaire entreprise
petrogaziaire en première ligne
lorsqu'on parle de greenwashing ça doit
pas vous étonner François Leman puisque
la moitié des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre dans ces 20 derniers années ont
été émises par 25 entreprises qui sont
toutes des entreprises pétrolières
Charbonnières ou gazières c'est vous qui
l'avez dit dans une interview que vous
avez donné à l'ADN en février dernier ah
il est évident que ces entreprises
aujourd'hui qui produisent l'essentiel
de l'énergie fossile qui aujourd'hui
représente encore à peu près 84% du mix
énergétique mondial c'est-à-dire de la
totalité de l'énergie produite chaque
jour dans le monde sont les principales
responsables du changement climatique et
donc c'est bien entendu sur elle que
l'action la plus forte est attendue et
c'est sur elle évidemment que ce braque
aussi les projecteurs et donc on
comprend bien qu'ils essaient de
s'engager dans des logiques de
greenwashing pour essayer de verdir leur
image le problème c'est que la réalité
ne trompe pas comme la rappeler lui ses
pinceau aujourd'hui elles ne sont pas du
tout sur une trajectoire de
décarbonation or c'est cette question de
trajectoire qui compte on comprend bien
naturellement que quand vous venez du
charbon du gaz ou du pétrole vous
puissiez pas en sortir du jour au
lendemain mais ce qui compte c'est les
nouveaux investissements et là ce qu'on
est en train d'insister c'est un
réinvestissement dans le pétrole et dans
le gaz en particulier autant la plupart
sont en train de sortir du charbon mais
dans le pétrole et dans le gaz on
continue à investir et donc le problème
de Total énergie c'est qu'ils
investissent à la fois dans les
renouvelables beaucoup trop peu et
beaucoup trop marginalement mais encore
dans les énergies fossiles parce
qu'elles restent très rentable c'est
comme si lors du classico PSG OM vous
souteniez Paris en première mi-temps et
Marseille en seconde mi-temps ça ne
marche pas il faut choisir et
aujourd'hui le problème que nous avons
c'est que les renouvelables ne sont pas
du tout en train de remplacer les
énergies fossiles c'est qu'elles
s'ajoute elles se superpose aux énergies
fossiles parce qu'on continue
aujourd'hui à investir dans les énergies
fossiles et c'est ça le problème c'est
très cynique pour reprendre votre
expression tout à l'heure parce que là
ce sont les lois capitalistiques qui
s'appliquent et autrement dit on
investit peu et tout à l'énergie parmi
d'autres investis encore très peu dans
ces énergies renouvelables parce que on
le dit assez froidement dans ce
documentaire les taux de rendement sont
beaucoup plus faibles que si on
investissait dans le pétrole et le gaz
tôt rendement de 5 à 6% qui n'a pas
l'air de satisfaire ni la direction
totale énergie et évidemment pas les
actionnaires de
Total énergie
même si on a constaté l'année dernière
notamment une explosion de des
investissements dans les énergies
renouvelables donc ce que François
German dit il a raison les deux
s'ajoutent on va pas dire qu'il y a pas
d'investissement dans les renouvelables
il y en a beaucoup en ce moment mais
le déclic au moment où les
investissements deviendront au moins
aussi rentable en matière d'énergie
renouvelables qu'elle ne le sont
aujourd'hui dans le pétrole et le gaz
vous avez deux problèmes le premier
problème c'est ce que dit d'ailleurs ce
qui est dit dans le reportage par le PDG
de Total il vous dit oui mais écoutez on
a encore besoin de beaucoup de pétrole
et de gaz donc c'est normal si moi je le
fais pas d'autres vont le faire donc ça
c'est le premier problème premier
problème qui a été résolu assez
clairement par l'Agence internationale
de l'énergie qui a dit en 2021
aujourd'hui pour tenir nos engagements
de l'accord de Paris et pour faire la
transition énergétique on a plus besoin
de nouveaux donc tout ce qui est
prospection dans les nouveaux gisements
c'est complètement à l'encontre de ce
qu'on doit faire sur les accords sur
l'accord de Paris deuxièmement on a
effectivement cette stratégie
capitalistique et cette stratégie des
investissements et là on a un vrai sujet
on a un vrai sujet parce que le monde
financier n'a pas encore fait sa mue et
d'ailleurs je rappelle qu'il y a un
sommet très important qui va se tenir à
Paris sur le financement de la
transition écologique qui est en train
d'être préparé et dans le cadre de cette
préparation on voit que c'est compliqué
on a des sujets sur les agences de
notation par exemple les agences de
notation se contrefiche éperdument du
climat et donc comme elles sont très
prescriptives pour un certain nombre
d'investissements la Banque Mondiale le
FMI c'est un sujet et donc je crois que
il ne faut pas regarder que les
entreprises pétrolières et gazières il
faut regarder aussi comment on est
finance et comment on fait pour changer
la donne de ce point de vue là je crois
que on en est encore loin mais que il y
a déjà quand même des stratégies des
États qui sont importantes on a
la France a notamment décidé avec Deep
et européens d'arrêter complètement les
garanties export sur les nouveaux
projets gaziers pétroliers garantie
export ça veut dire le soutien d'un pays
pour faire une forme d'assurance sur sur
ces produits et puis on voit que il
commence à y avoir un certain nombre de
banques un certain nombre d'assurance
qui refusent d'investir dans des projets
notamment comme le projet de l'Ouganda
je pense que c'est un système qu'il faut
encourager alors vous essayez de
l'encourager évidemment avec la même
finance parce que ça c'est un autre
problème abordé mais c'est la suite
logique c'est-à-dire il faudrait pour
parler lorsqu'on parle de greenwashing
il faut aussi s'en prendre à ceux qui
financent ces entreprises qui
elles-mêmes utilisent le greenwashing en
l'occurrence commençons par les
industries petrogaziaires alors on pense
aux assurances
et on pense bien sûr aux banques alors
parmi les banques il y en a une qui est
dans votre collimateur en particulier
c'est la BNP expliquez-nous quel est le
problème de la BNP peut-être ce qui va
nous permettre de prendre de bien
comprendre ce problème de greenwashing
utiliser cette fois par les organismes
financiers qui finance des entreprises
du type total énergie alors il faut
d'abord pour faire le lien en effet
peut-être rappeler que les acteurs
financiers que ce soit les banques les
investisseurs ou les assureurs
fournissent les services qui sont
indispensables aux grandes
multinationales de l'énergie parmi
lesquels on va trouver total énergie
pour maintenir leur opération et aussi
développer de nouvelles infrastructures
que elles le Soi développée dans le
secteur de la transition énergétique les
énergies renouvelables ou dans les
énergies les énergies fossilées donc les
acteurs financiers ont un rôle
extrêmement important dans la transition
puisque leur décision d'aujourd'hui
façonne le monde de demain donc si on
veut faire la transition c'est dès
maintenant que les acteurs financiers
arrêter de financer les projets qui
ajoutent du carbone a déjà pour vous il
faut fermer le robinet concernant ces
financements pour tous pour empêcher le
développement de projets qui nous mène
bien au-delà des 1,5 degrés et utiliser
le pouvoir qu'on les acteurs financiers
pour contraindre les entreprises
lorsqu’ils clientes à se transformer
parce qu'au-delà de la règle d'expansion
il va falloir pousser nos entreprises à
aussi organiser la fermeture de milliers
d'infrastructures tout en prenant en
compte les enjeux autour notamment de la
reconversion des salariés et lorsqu'on
s'intéresse à ces sujets là et ben on
voit que en effet on a en France des
grands acteurs financiers notamment dans
le secteur bancaire qui malgré leur
grand discours en matière climatique
continue d'aggraver la situation en
finançant sans condition les
multinationales parmi lesquels on va
trouver total énergie et c'est notamment
le cas de BNP Paribas qui est la
première banque européenne a financer
l'expansion des énergies des fossiles au
niveau international avec rien qu'en
2022 15 milliards de financement alloués
aux 100 entreprises qui développent le
plus de nouveaux projets 15 milliards il
faut se rendre compte c'est la moitié de
l'ensemble des financements que toutes
les banques européennes réunies ont
accordé à l'expansion pétrolière et
gazière en 2022 et là il y a un point
qui est extrêmement important de
comprendre on a une banque qui ne
s'engage à ne plus soutenir les projets
comme e-cop les nouveaux projets
directement mais ça c'est une toute
petite partie de ces financements au
secteur énergétique tant que Total
énergie que BNP pardon continue de faire
des chèques à Total énergie sans
condition et bien elle se rend complices
des impacts de ces activités sur les
écosystèmes les populations et le climat
BNP Paribas établissement européen qui
soutient le plus les énergies fossiles
selon quasiment toutes les études
orchestrées par des ONG
bon alors là qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
et surtout quel est le constat que vous
faites le même constat cette question du
financement c'est vraiment aujourd'hui
un des points aveugles de la lutte
contre le changement climatique et tout
part de là en réalité si de nouveaux
projets de forage pétroliers ou
d'investissement dans le gaz existe
c'est parce qu'ils sont financés c'est
parce qu'ils sont assurés et donc si on
veut que l'économie puisse décarboner il
faut un moment donné que le secteur de
la finance joue le jeu de manière à
rendre les énergies décarbonées plus
compétitives et plus rentable que les
énergies fossiles tant qu'on investira
aujourd'hui les montants gigantesques
que Lucie pinson a mentionné dans les
énergies fossiles et bien on aura une
situation malheureusement ou les
compagnies énergétiques continueront à
générer leur plus gros profits sur le
pétrole et le gaz et donc elles n'ont
aucune raison d'en sortir et ça c'est
vraiment fondamental et malheureusement
la situation est aggravée par la crise
énergétique et la guerre en Ukraine
puisque toutes les compagnies
pétrolières gazières et Charbonnières
ont réalisé des profits records
chaudière Ramco a réalisé l'an dernier
161 milliards de dollars de bénéfice net
il faut se rendre compte de ce que
représente ce chiffre et donc tant qu'on
aura de telles bénéfices encouragés par
les investissements et bien il y aura
aucune motivation pour les industries
pétrolières et gazières à sortir des
énergies fossiles alors question de lui
aussi les énergies fossiles elles auront
une fin c'est les réserves vont
s'épuiser à quel échéance non je pense
pas qu'elles auront une fin c'est-à-dire
que sans cesse on est en train de
découvrir de nouveaux gisements non
conventionnels on a parlé du pic
pétrolier et puis on a découvert le
pétrole de schiste le pétrole non
conventionnel le changement climatique
lui-même en faisant fondre les glaces du
gros de lad donne accès à de nouveaux
gisements d'hydrocarbures donc si on
très clair si on compte sur le pic de
production des énergies fossiles pour
sortir des énergies fossiles on risque
d'être encore là avant la fin du siècle
il faut aujourd'hui une action
volontariste pour laisser dans le
sous-sol des énergies auxquelles on ne
doit pas toucher si nous exploitons tout
le pétrole et tout le gaz on est parti
sur un scénario la plus 6 degrés c'est
la fin pour tout le monde
ça sera plus cher ça sera de plus en
plus cher mais c'est pas encore le cas
maintenant donc ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il y a pas une action
volontariste pour les laisser dans le
sous-sol on va pas y arriver oui et puis
il y a quand même un sujet c'est que
même au-delà des investissements qu'il
doit faire
on peut regarder aussi leur processus de
production et tout ce qu'ils émettent en
tant que tel dans leur processus de
production c'est à dire que quand on a
des entreprises comme Total qui nous
disent on est des acteurs de l'accord de
Paris c'est incroyable de voir que au
niveau de leur process ils ne font pas
le minimum on a vu ce qui se passait au
Texas par exemple sur les émanations de
méthane il y a du gaz de schiste suite à
extraction du gaz de schiste au minimum
il pourrait au moins capter ce méthane
et empêcher qu'il s'échappe ce serait la
moindre des choses et pour moi c'est ça
la différence entre une entreprise
sérieuse et une entreprise qui fait du
greenwashing une entreprise sérieuse
elle va regarder tout ce qu'elle aimait
en termes de gaz à effet de serre et va
essayer de réduire tout ce qu'elle peut
là il y a un article qui est sorti il y
a pas longtemps du directeur général de
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
fatimérole qui dit que rien qu'avec
en récupérant le méthane qui est qui
était mis en évitant qu'il parte dans
l'atmosphère ou qu'il soit brûlé dans
des torchères les entreprises
pétrolières et gazières pourraient
diminuer des trois quarts de trois
quarts leurs émissions de méthane
sachant que le méthane est le gaz qui
est entre guillemets le plus intéressant
à réduire vite parce que c'est un gaz
qui émet beaucoup beaucoup de d'effets
de serre de gaz à effet de serre et donc
qui fait partie de nos priorités si on
veut baisser rapidement nos gaz à effet
de serre d'ici à 2030 mais ça ils ne
font pas donc à un moment alors que ça
ne leur coûterait pas grand chose notre
d'autant plus ils vendent le gaz qu'ils
ont récupéré sur le court terme le
méthane est 30 fois plus nocif que le
dioxyde de carbone pour donner un ordre
valider ou téléspectateurs oui peut-être
que il est indispensable d'agir sur les
deux niveaux où il faut arrêter d'en
ajouter des nouveaux projets et en même
temps il faut décarboner les méthodes de
production actuelle sur les
infrastructures existantes et notamment
en effet pour limiter les émissions de
méthane en évitant du coup par
anticipation un risque potentiel de
greenwashing futur à savoir que
l'installation de techniques pour
réduire les émissions liées à des
infrastructures existantes soit utilisée
par l'industrie et par les financeurs
comme une excuse pour du coup en
développer plus parce que plus qu'on
peut faire on peut faire propre et ben
on peut développer des nouveaux projets
on l'a beaucoup vu sur avec l'industrie
du charbon avec le mythe du charbon
propre et bien on voit poindre ce risque
pour le secteur gazier avec l'idée que
le gaz serait une solution moins
carbonée en plus on peut réduire les
émissions en utilisant ces technologies
et donc on va en financer davantage et
ça c'est un énorme risque de de
greenwashing qui pointe autant du côté
des industriels que du côté des acteurs
financiers bon Barbara Pompidou une fois
qu'on a vu ça une fois qu'on s'est dit
et qu'on a bâti un constat qui est pas
très très optimiste à ce stade lorsqu'on
parle de greenwashing il y en a beaucoup
qui ne jouent pas le jeu dans le domaine
financier dans le domaine pétrochimique
dans le domaine prétérogazier de quels
outils bénéficie aujourd'hui un
gouvernement prenant peut-être l'exemple
du gouvernement français vous connaissez
bien le sujet pour lutter contre le
green bolching qu'y a-t-il qui
existe-t-il dans la boîte à outils
législative pour lutter contre le
greenwashing on parle de publicité
mensongère si on a bien compris
on a intégré dans la loi qui m'a
résilience qui a été publié l'année
dernière il y a deux ans maintenant
d'ailleurs
un principe simple c'est que le
greenwashing est maintenant vu comme une
pratique commerciale trompeuse donc
c'est un terme juridique mais qui permet
de sanctionner ce genre d'attitude c'est
de ça manquait dans notre arsenal
législatif et c'était important de
l'avoir pour aussi dire que on ne
pouvait plus n'importe quoi et il y a un
certain nombre de publicités qui depuis
ont été interdites alors je donne un
exemple parce que on n'est pas qu'en
France il y a d'autres pays qui font la
même chose il y a eu l'affaire Lufthansa
ou Lufthansa a une publicité interdite
parce que elle disait clairement que
grâce à eux ils baissaient les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre j'ai pu les
termes exact mais on était sur quelque
chose d'évident donc le fait de faire
aussi d'une amazigh je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut mettre au jour ce
qu'il se passe mettre au jour les enjeux
et informer nos concitoyens j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer les membres de la
Convention citoyenne pour le climat j'ai
pu constater à quel point le fait de
faire comprendre les enjeux à des
personnes qui sont pas forcément
informés plus que ça qu'elles prennent
conscience des enjeux change des
comportements parce que vous aurez des
industries comme Total à juste titre qui
vous diront oui oui tout le monde est
écologiste mais quand il s'agit de
changer ses études pour pour utiliser
moins de produits pétroliers il y a plus
grand monde et
ils n'ont pas tort ou en tout cas ils
s'appuient là-dessus donc la réponse ça
doit être aussi une réponse collective
et une réponse aussi qui doit être
portée politiquement je pense que les
politiques ont un rôle à jouer ce qui se
passe dans l'école de ces entreprises
ces multinationales le pouvoir du
politique existe bel et bien alors je
suis une grande défenseuse je suis une
grande défenseuse du pouvoir des
politiques je pense que si le politique
abdique ses responsabilités et bien
effectivement il y a plus rien à faire
je et dans ces cas-là moi j'arrête de
faire de la politique on doit se battre
en tant que politique pour dire que ce
ne sont pas aux grandes multinationales
de faire la loi et on peut y arriver
pour peu qu'on ait une vision et le
courage de le faire
c'est important mais je pense qu'il faut
rappeler aussi que mais ce qu'il existe
des critères aujourd'hui j'ai vu que
l'Union européenne voulait faire le tri
des gros actionnaires de Total énergie
c'est quand même l'État français et donc
moi j'habite aussi les pouvoirs publics
pas seulement à faire de la
réglementation mais utiliser leur
pouvoir d'actionnaires pour contraindre
les dirigeants de l'entreprise a changé
de stratégie et à changer de trajectoire
et souvent on oublie que un des premiers
actionnaires quand même des compagnies
pétrolières gazières et Charbonnières
c'est souvent l'État lui-même
garanties export je peux vous dire
j'espère que je pense que vous avez
plein d'idées sur le sujet comment
est-ce qu'on peut contraindre les
entreprises à ne pas utiliser le
greenwashing je pense que ce que dit
français
le pouvoir de du rôle de l'État
actionnaire extrêmement important et on
peut que déplorer le fait que l'État
s'est opposé à la résolution des
actionnaires voté il y a peu à
l'assemblée générale d'engie et qui
poussait à engie non pas radicalement
transformé son activité mais a déjà
rajouter d'une politique climatique
complète et à rendre public cette cette
stratégie bien entendu au-delà de la
politique de vote et des crédits exports
il y a tous les autres subventions aux
énergies fossiles ou même les soutiens
diplomatiques qui peuvent être encore
accordé aux multinationales des énergies
fossiles comme c'est le cas à l'heure
actuelle par le gouvernement français
pour le projet ICO porté par Total
énergie en Ouganda et puis après sur la
question des très bien décrits dans ce
film qui nous demande de voir et après
sur la question des flux financiers il y
a encore énormément de choses à faire
par exemple on a aujourd'hui des
investisseurs qui continuent de vendre à
leurs clients des produits dit durables
qui contiennent des entreprises de
l'aviation des énergies fossiles et bah
ça c'est inadmissible et il faut que le
gouvernement interviennent notamment
pour pousser la MF l'Autorité des
marchés financiers et bien à faire son
travail de gendarmes et à sanctionner
les acteurs qui continueraient de mentir
à leurs clients et bien entendu l'État
doit s'assurer enfin s'imposer cette
même discip pour ses propres produits
dilabellisés notamment le label ISR qui
est en pleine révision à l'heure
actuelle et qui pourrait encore contenir
des énergies fossiles malgré la révision
qui arrive bon bah ça c'est inadmissible
il faut absolument exclure tout
entreprises les énergies fossiles de ce
label que comme tout le monde comprend
comme étant responsable et donc ne
contenant pas de majeur parce qu'il faut
avoir une politique de sanction est-ce
que c'est possible vis-à-vis de ces
entreprises alors on a cité les Petro
gazières il y a des entreprises je vais
citer quelques noms quand même un
Coca-Cola Adidas Carrefour distributeur
revient souvent aussi parmi ces
entreprises qui pratiquent le
greenwashing les entreprises bancaires
évidemment vous en avez cité
quelques-unes je pense que 1 il faut
réglementer au titre de la publicité
mensongère tout simplement une compagnie
n'a pas le droit de faire de publicité
mensongère deux il faut quand même
rappeler que ça ne marche qu'à moitié
quand même mais que aujourd'hui les
consommateurs les citoyens sont de moins
en moins dupe notamment grâce à l'action
des ONG l'image de Total énergie c'est
quand même considérablement dégradé dans
l'opinion française on voit bien que
leur stratégie de greenwashing ça ne
marche pas et je pense que les
entreprises qui s'engagent là-dedans
prennent un risque réputationnel énorme
3 il faut que les pouvoirs publics
jouent le rôle y compris en matière de
banque et d'assurance le plus gros
actionnaire de BNP Paribas c'est l'État
belge deux administrateurs au conseil
d'administration qu'est-ce qu'ils font
là encore il y a aucune réponse
avoir la majorité mais je suis d'accord
avec clairement mais d'accord avec ce
qui a été dit après il y a aussi des
réglementations importantes on a une loi
en France et qui a été d'ailleurs
reprise au niveau européen sur le devoir
de vigilance des entreprises c'est un
point important on est encore elle date
de 2017 on est encore au balbutiement de
de sa mise en oeuvre je crois que c'est
ce sont des bases intéressantes parce
que cela
responsabilise des entreprises sur toute
la chaîne de valeur ce qui n'était pas
le cas auparavant ça
complète ce qu'on appelle aussi les
politiques de responsabilité sociétale
des et environnementales des entreprises
qui sont en plein essor aujourd'hui qui
peuvent être un vivier de greenwashing
si on y prête pas garde mais qui peuvent
être aussi des bons des bons outils de
contrôle de l'activité des entreprises
on a un certain nombre d'outils la
question c'est de les utiliser et c'est
surtout de faire prendre conscience que
on n'est pas désarmé face à des
entreprises qui voudraient faire
n'importe quoi et moi je pense aussi que
nous sommes dans un moment charnière de
notre histoire on est dans un moment où
on réussira à se sortir du guêpier de ce
réchauffement climatique si on construit
ensemble une alternative
je crois que les acteurs gaziers
pétroliers ont tout intérêt à s'y
intéresser autrement qu'en surface parce
que on est en train de construire un
avenir aussi on est en train de
construire une nouvelle société et je
pense que c'est peut-être ce bout là qui
manque à nos concitoyens vous parliez
tout à l'heure du fait que effectivement
il faut complètement revoir notre
économie ça veut dire des changements
dans les filières ça veut dire aussi des
réorientations des formations
différentes ça veut dire des métiers
entiers qui vont disparaître d'autres
qui vont apparaître c'est quelque chose
de passionnant à construire mais qu'on
néglige un peu parce que on a le poids
de cela qui finalement nous
enchaînent un peu à un passé dont il
faut qu'on réussisse à sortir
c'est la fin de cette émission je suis
aussi noté que la Commission de
Bruxelles ou les faire le tri parmi les
labels verts et donc ils ont relevé un
certain nombre d'indicateurs et balayer
150 allégations de Type 0 carbone
emballage à base de matériaux cyclés ou
encore emprunt de climatiques réduites
qui figurait sur des emballages ou des
publicités bilan 53% d'entre elles
contenaient des informations vagues
trompeuses et non étayées 40% étaient
des nuées de tout fondement
j'ajoute le bilan est tout de même
l'harmonisation des réglementations sur
les pollueurs payeurs je pense que c'est
aussi un sujet important parce que la
question des finances va être importante
dans les années à venir vous voulez
avoir le mot de la fin
mais il est il est malheureusement on
serait en 3% enfin c'est énorme mais ça
montre bien que il y a une place à
prendre pour tous les régulateurs je
parlais de la MF de la CPR qui doivent
aujourd'hui s'imposer ils ont comme
mandat de s'assurer que l'information
qui est transmise au marché et
crédible et valable et bien il faut pas
avoir fait beaucoup d'années d'études
pour comprendre que des entreprises
d'énergie fossiles qui se retrouvent
dans des fonds d'investissement dit
durable
ça relève du greenwashing et que il faut
absolument sanctionner tant qu'il n'y a
pas de sanction les acteurs seront on
peut s'attendre à ce que bien
normalement il continue de de perpétuer
ces pratiques vous êtes un habitué de la
prospective à quand la fin du
greenwashing avec tout ce qu'on s'est
dit là avec les mesures les la boîte
outils qui existent qui existent qui va
peut-être se compléter d'ailleurs dans
les années qui viennent pas pour tout de
suite à mon avis parce que plus on va
s'engager dans la décarbonation de
l'économie plus il va y avoir des
demandes très fortes du public pour que
les entreprises se verdissent celle qui
ne voudront pas le faire s'engageront de
plus en plus dans des stratégies de
greenwashing donc à mon avis c'est pas
pour demain mais ces entreprises seront
tôt ou tard sanctionnées soit par
législateur soit par les consommateurs
voilà ça sera bel et bien le mot de la
fin cette fois merci vraiment à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à cette émission
débat doc aujourd'hui consacré au
greenwashing après ce documentaire
consacré à Total énergie que vous en
avons eu le plaisir de vous présenter
dans cette émission vos réactions
#dads sur Twitter bien entendu nos
invités seront d'ailleurs là pour réagir
à ce que ce qu'on sait ces réactions
merci à sel massalik qui m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission prochain
rendez-vous avec des badox ça sera bien
sûr avec son documentaire et son débat
très bientôt
[Musique]